I'm on a lecture tour of Australia big
cities Sydney and delayed Melbourne but
now I'm somewhere special a small town
called Bendigo not far from Melbourne
and the reason I've come here is because
of this building behind me
the Bendigo Discovery Centre because
I've heard there's something really
quite exciting inside let's go in so Wow
look at this but that's not why we're
here we're here because there's a
touring exhibition about the periodic
table which started on the island of
Tasmania off the coast of Australia and
here it is
this exhibit has been assembled for the
International Year of chemistry you can
see I'm wearing the symbol of the
International year here and the RACI the
Royal Australian chemical Institute held
an auction of the elements people had to
big money for I want cesium or I want
francium or I want hydrogen and they use
that money to pay Tasmanian artists to
design a picture for that element these
artists then put their work together to
make this periodic table and over here
and it's nothing to do with the exhibits
is our periodic table of videos QR codes
periodic table and we made a video about
that before so let's get back to the
business what they've done is some of
the things are really quite obvious why
they've chosen them if you look up here
at fluorine they've got teeth you
remember that fluoride will stop your
teeth being attacked so easily by the
acid in your mouth there are other ones
which are really quite fun so if we look
up here to gallium which was discovered
in France and so gallium isn't an named
of the name gall for France but this one
is quite a pun because you've Seaton's
got a cockerel there and the person who
discovered it the scientist was called
Lacock which means a cockerel in French
and also gallium or galaz in Latin means
a cockerel so this one has quite a
subtle pan though I'm not quite sure why
it's got a radioactive symbol there
that's it's just a ventilator so that
the cockerel doesn't suffocate so over
here we have meitnerium which was named
after Lisa Meitner who discovered the
explanation of nuclear fission but I
think she looks a bit like Mary Poppins
here we have two
which I think that's rather nice it has
a turbine from a jet engine from an
aeroplane because the turbine blades are
often made of titanium I quite like
aluminum you can see it has ring pool
drinks cans which is quite a practical
illusion though perhaps drinks cans are
not something we should be terribly
proud of they're very wasteful so
there's really quite a coincidence about
us being in Bendigo because this town
Bendigo was actually named after a boxer
a prizefighter one that fought without
gloves called Bendigo who came from
Nottingham the city where my university
is so all the places in Australia this
is one of the very few that has a direct
connection with Nottingham and here we
are and we come and we find not only the
exhibition of the periodic table but
even the periodic table from Nottingham
as well so it's really quite a
coincidence
there is strontium which is formed
strontium 90 is formed in nuclear
explosions and I think here there is a
representation of the devastation
probably of Hiroshima after the nuclear
explosion
I think this periodic table is really
quite fun it doesn't have any
information on it at all except the
atomic number and the name of the
element but what it does have is a
picture which makes you think why on
earth has the artist chosen this or that
and there's some booklets down the side
which can tell people about what the
artist was thinking but from our point
of view it's cheating to look at this
because still spoils the fun you've got
to try and guess what is your one
favorite
I think it really has to be hassium
because I really since we started doing
these periodic videos I fallen in love
with hassium I have absolutely no idea
what this picture is but there was a
dinner held or lunch party held in
Sydney when I was there and each of the
tables was named after one of the
elements the dinner was organized by the
RACI so they actually used these
pictures and I took a photograph at the
table called hassium my table was a bit
boring I was on silicon up here and it
looks okay but it was nothing very
exciting and my next-door neighbor took
it the label down because she couldn't
see the person sitting opposite her
there's one more thing that's really
exciting there's a chemistry teacher
from a large secondary school in
Melbourne who's driven all the way
nearly two hours to meet us in Bendigo
and kate is not only an excellent an
enthusiastic chemistry teacher but
there's a picture of her class just in
front of my desk which she sent in as
one of the pictures for our viewers when
Brady was making a film about it and she
also brought me a really nice card from
all the children in her class so I'd
like to say to them thank you for the
card and to wish all the children
studying chemistry in Australia great
success and I hope a lot of you will be
able to see this periodic table as it
travels around the country come on okay
which one's your favourite my favourite
is carbon
I like it because oh thank you I like
carbon because it's got pictures of the
gum nuts